and you know when people say um rodney
king was
what sparked the riots it really hurts
me
okay because there was many things that
sparked the riots including that korean
lady
who shot that black girl yeah 16 year
old black girl
that's what i here's okay i want to say
anything about koreans
all right i know i make fun of the the
filipinos a lot
and other group races right but i wanted
to be
to be uh sensitive about it yeah
yeah i would tell you about koreans man
they could be bastards and what that
lady did
right shooting that young teenage
african-american girl
for over nothing right it's a shame on
koreans
and and and it's something that we have
to correct ourselves as well
race do you think that it was a race
thing with a korean lady yes
right yeah yeah yeah and it's like you
you're going to open up liquor stores in
impoverished areas to take
it's a drug basically they're taking
advantage of you're taking advantage of
yeah you're selling them alcohol
right which is a drug right so you're a
drug dealer
and i understand you want to make money
but it's like um
you know i get it from the other side
too definitely i totally get it and you
know what
people are allowed to browse
you mean what does that mean like you
know i know they get no like when people
come in like
walk around people walking oh you're
allowed to browse they say no browsing
yeah you i can't look at the ingredients
the calories or the calorie count
[ __ ] not wow right [ __ ] you koreans
like let them grow up let them know let
them touch them yeah
let them know and if they steal it you
can shoot them
i'm kidding no i'm kidding you can steal
let them steal little steal don't shoot
don't call the enforcement i played a
lot of starcraft too and i learned a lot
about korean culture
yeah because it's like huge there like
esports and gaming is huge there yeah
and it seems like a real really strict
really tight tough tough people
there was a korean lady that was i just
saw this on
i on instagram a korean lady who
disappeared
okay she was missing for 10 years
you know where they found her where in a
gaming cafe
just sitting there sitting there for 10
years playing
a game wow she got so addicted that she
decided to just cut everything off
that's real yeah you see that other
documentary about what we saw on hbo
about the japanese couple who had a baby
i think i've heard
right they had a baby right but the baby
died
because they didn't feed it for 10 days
they were in a 40-man raid yeah and then
yourself they didn't go to prison and
guess what
they had another baby what right
but the game gaming is fun though but
yeah
that's the world the story of the story
i guess
it's a big really big problem yeah yeah
in korea it is a problem
that's all i do yeah i could have been
way bigger than this
than i am you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] die
someday you're gonna die you're gonna
end up you're gonna die i'm happy to
hear you're enjoying yeah
because you can work so [ __ ] hard and
you cannot spend any time playing video
games
yeah and you're gonna dine at least
you've spent some time joining
[Music]
you